hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to riddle school - no no
it's been a while since I played the
first riddle school and I meant to get
back to this lot sooner but things got
in the way and then I totally forgot
about the series and I meant to do the
whole series with all the different
games in it and even riddles transferred
games
oh he's bored okay
welcome to real school - ah Oh what is
this
I love the pun on the wall over there
but I'm not sure why we're here man that
guy's twitchy and sad ah coins good are
these things that I need hi teacher how
you doing that's a band director mr.
oboe he only got hired because is his
name okay cold what's that about I know
nothing of music but much of English
that doesn't help anybody hey Fred can
you help me escape school again
I have a whistle as if that'd be useful
it might help can I have it only if you
have a dollar I almost have a dollar I
got 75 cents is there another quarter
hiding up in the notes up there maybe a
quarter note okay now that we're off to
an incredible start let's go outside now
while mr. oboe is watching
okay so there's got to be another
quarter up here it's got to be hiding in
the quarter notes I can't just be a pun
it's got to actually be a thing right no
no no oh there it isn't on the drumset
okay I got a dollar
Thanks well what did he do the poor
guy did it kill him is he dead
where's everybody dead what did he
freeze oh happy man's not so happy
anymore
okay bye everybody who's been
incapacitated now that was a sharp idea
I don't get that
mrs. sleep oh isn't that interesting she
stopped at the letter Z
mrs. sleep she hasn't moved since last
month she might be dead
did we drag someone to find someone to
drag her out of the room and replace her
she's here to stay
it's kind of boring but at least we
don't have to do any work okay he's in
sleep mode that's very funny I don't
feel blue okay ah ah okay
some trombone slide oil and thirty cents
I don't know what you're gonna do with
mixture but it sounds like a fun time I
suppose
can't get out yeah no joke you can't
counselor has skis like last time oh
okay then not going back in there
exactly so what am I gonna do with all
this trombone lube oh hi hello I seem to
remember we being in a similar
precarious situation before what are you
doing here what what are you doing there
the closet is standing by yourself not
really an office mister some lights are
off doors locked he's probably
masturbating seawater doing something
about that I don't break for duck sir
how many ducks how about the women's
bathroom No why not
doors lock lights are off men's room
anybody have any toilet paper uh no I
don't have any C cigs are backed up okay
nothing to do in here how about some sly
dial you could lube up your pooper I
don't know why that helped you in any
capacity but it's just something that I
said okay got another quarter
oh no that's a dime I got got 40 cents I
checked all the other lockers they don't
seem to open so I bowed over hello I
want a cookie well I don't have anything
the same okay wow they made a second one
okay probably won't need that back door
unlocked but it's blocked by dumpster
okay teachers loud why are you in here
let's see I was in the hallway I got
permission to buy a cookie I saw cow
burst into flames
what's up cow burst into flames who's
nuts crazy was it my cow what it looked
like uh fat white with black spots
oh okay never mind then damn it I almost
had that see bursts into flames
that doesn't convince me minds the
story's true I didn't believe said they
didn't sound that believable to begin
with if you don't have anything useful
Oh some of the cow bursting into flames
isn't good which teacher sent you here
uh no teacher just the cookie machine
okay never mind that so this is actually
gonna be a conundrum mister oboe
okay how about miss sleep confirmation
miss sleep okay
mr. sum that's me okay
pratik this isn't working then alright
see alright fine there's got to be a
solution here who's wrong room oh
it's gotta be away okay so I gotta get a
note what I gotta do is I gotta go get a
note from the band room how about the
janitor you want some slide all oh okay
wait there's a roll of toilet paper in
the vent
how does that make any sense I would go
in and get it but the vent cover is
rusted shut
well it's good thing I got some good old
fashioned trombone oil don't know how
that beats rust but I lubed it up good
now slid right in between the cracks
all right let's deliver this toilet
favor to the guy here there you go buddy
could've rolled it under whoo Sh what
are you doing okay bye no thanks or
nothing yeah okay but I got a mop do I
give this back to the janitor because
somehow he loses his how about him
up where'd you find my mom for some
reason it was in the toilet okay thanks
for returning here's my last dime well
now I have 50 cents and no wasted on
those schools cheesy pencils that
doesn't help me at all what I don't have
enough money for a cookie how am I gonna
oh wait a minute what are you doing back
here you were in the teachers lounge
have a nice visit
hurry back when you're finished okay
can't see were needed civil edition I'm
a little confused okay so he's back and
she's back so that means that in some of
these in in this room there's got to be
like a quarter or something in one of
these rooms and then I got a find in
them's gonna help me get the cookie
because the cookie is 75 cents according
to the thing of the teachers loud ah
there we go found it okay I got 75 cents
now right that's enough to be able to
get a cookie it's enough to be able to
have I always wrote it is do I need to
lube up the cookie machine I've got 75
cents right goddamn it huh okay now this
is a conundrum and I don't know how to
solve it
Oh oh well that was how was I supposed
to know that it was literally no way
that I would have known that oh man I
hate that that's like my least favorite
thing about these puzzle games when you
have to click it like the back of
something but anyway I got it I got it I
happened by able to babble BAM
okay blamed I blamed it to blam oh and I
got a cookie hey big guy you want a
cookie I got a cookie for you I've also
got some Lube if you want that I've have
a I have a whole handful of Lube wow
it's fast okay hello that's five yes as
its name one election vote five okay
happy face bowling ball cabinets are
locked hello is somebody in here hi
mister mister are you doing may I leave
the school
oh all right bye then sucker piggy took
the key okay goodbye
am I out of here oh that's all she wrote
that was at least oh oh no oh yes okay
we're okay
kachunk you put it in upside down but I
won't criticize you about that freedom
oh yes glorious freedom okay so that's
the end of riddle school - there's a
whole bunch of other riddle riddle
school games and I'll say basically the
same thing that I said in the last one
these are fun little adventures in it
it's like a it's like a time capsule I
don't know if I said this unless when
I'm scared making that up as I go but
it's like a time capsule
going through the series I imagine I
have never played it before but it's
like a time capsule going through and
seeing like the evolution of the
designer of the game and also like the
evolution of technology as it goes long
and like the complexity getting more and
more things so it's a really fun series
with a lot of like puns which if you
like that you get a lot of that in your
life so thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know if you won't see
the other games in the series and the
comments below and thanks again for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye